it's time for drew's news your spooky
little news desk haunted by good news
ghost
and with me at the desk is milo casper
[Applause]
i love that you call me pumpkin i might
just stick with pumpkin i love pumpkin
um
well i'm gonna open up with a little
personal story what so i ordered um some
cat food
what uh because i was like oh god i'm
out of cat food so i got just a couple
little cans to tide me over for the
night okay and a bag of treats and then
my bag arrived and i opened it up and it
was ice cream
like literally it was uh the tonight
dough and then there were other tubs of
ice cream and i'm like
okay first of all
this is not good for the cleanse i'm on
second of all that poor person out there
just wanted to eat their feelings and
enjoy their evening
now has
friskies oh my god and i've got bed and
cherries
oh i hope they're watching right now and
they're like drew barrymore stole my ice
cream
whoever you are i'm gonna write this
wrong and i'm gonna get you a bunch of
ice
[Applause]
it's cream halloween on uh sunday yeah
which is i love when it lands on a
weekend so uh this year um i'm gonna go
big and um we always decorate my
vestibule the girls and i and for those
who don't know what is your vestibule
it's just a little entryway
it's a way to get from the elevator to
the door in a few inches okay here's my
last uh year's vestibule
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay you go hard and that is like
it's like the size of a coat closet so
we really maximize it
but you know i now i want you to check
out um what i did this year
welcome hahaha
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you are not the only one who loves
halloween like this businesses are
barely keeping up with all the halloween
spirit fortune reports that retailers
have been selling out of all things
spooky inflatable gravestones gigantic
12-foot skeletons and the hottest
halloween decoration item on tiktok
right now it's got like
six million views is something it's a
ghost rug what yeah a ghost drug look at
this
this is what everybody wants they're
sold out everywhere drew are you gonna
incorporate one of these i i mean i
don't think i can because you cannot get
that that's exactly what i was gonna say
good luck getting one because they are
out they are out out out you know what i
a lot i'm a very festive person but i'm
also a very practical person so for each
holiday i give myself one container like
plastic storage bin of decor uh because
i'm sorry this rug is cute but we're
gonna go the other 11 months of the year
well um we actually have a die-hard
halloween fan here catherine
hello
um okay well um
this year what are you doing for
halloween i think the theme is going to
be believe it or not um we may just do
something a little bit towards like
mediterranean you know halloween so i'd
wear something that's greek somebody
else would be a you know italian
somebody else would be spanish and
just make it more like international so
it's not just regular halloween if you
since you love halloween so much i'm
curious how many bins do you have
a lot there's probably 10 in my attic 10
bins
yeah
i love that
and
don't you wish you could get your hands
on one of those ghost rugs oh absolutely
i didn't know about it until like
recently and i looked at this really
that's the coolest thing if everybody's
got i gotta have it
and you can't get it right no no i know
we can't either either i wish i wish i
could just snap my fingers and make one
just show up right now for
oh my gosh
[Applause]
[Music]
for you
all right next up it's time to taste the
season's newest latest trend in food
news
okay
what do we have um i mean you have to
take this story okay she's gonna eat oh
yeah well every year we marvel at all
the things pumpkin spice right it's like
as soon as august hits everything's
pumpkin and it's all fall along well now
food and wine reports you can get a
little pumpkin spice in your cup of
noodles they've taken pumpkin spice
and oh this these are two things that i
do not know it should be combined
um i'm not gonna lie it smells
interesting
that smells super interesting
wait um can you join us on this we've
got a br a brave taste tester joining us
on this expedition it's well
it's like the right smell but the wrong
item or yeah
yes it really does smell a lot like
pumpkin spice like it should be a pie
here yes it's not like a bun but it's
noodles all right well
and tell me what you think what's the
verdict
uh what do you think alyssa i think it's
okay
but um
yeah i mean see like my daughter who's
the queen of ramen noodles and we'll
cook them in the shower with just the
shower water i could see her finishing
this yeah it's a thing
wow
she takes the hot water from the shower
and puts it in moodle it was a boy camp
thing so you send them care packages and
one of the main items you send to sleep
boy camp is ramen and they would call it
shower ramen because they didn't have
microwaves they didn't stove this
pumpkin ramen and shower ramen what is
going on
before we go we've got a big style alert
it is a trend everywhere it's not one
but two trends making a big comeback
fashion experts say this fall it's all
about cowboys and cargos cowboy boots
have been everywhere look here's gigi
hadid priyanka chopra kendall jenner uh
and cargo pants aren't just for plumbers
anymore they check out these high
fashion cargo pants by rihanna kanye zoe
deutsch all with a different little take
well today since we're being adventurous
on the show we thought we'd throw
caution to the wind and try them both
yeah
both fashion trends at the same time
this is a tv first people you ready for
the fashion show drew um all right we've
been hiding it the whole time back here
look hey
[Applause]
here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you